- Well, we've actually trained athletes,
you can say on the, sort of,
academic side of training.
You would not have necessarily imagined,
and guess what, it improves
their performance on the field.
Well, it's happening for a couple reasons.
One reason is that
you're training a person
to be more alert, more on
the ball, more engaged,
and then you're heavily
exercising machinery
in the brain that's controlling
its capacity to learn.
It's an interesting thing
about athletic training.
Focus is massively on the body.
And that's sort of in the level
of professional athletics,
that's sort of to the peak.
I mean, how could you
improve a great athlete
on the professional level physically?
But, they're all improvable cognitively.
They're all improvable in here.
Then you still have a ways
to go by training in here.
How about smarter?
How about quicker in
their decision-making?
How about seeing more and
responding to it more accurately?
Logic, reasoning, and
the brain receiver itself
that's controlling
learning are all improving.
Now, I'm gonna use my brain
for some other purpose,
maybe some very different purpose.
Maybe I'm gonna throw or catch a baseball.
It matters.
I now have a different machine than I had
before I spent all of
that time in the class.
On the Kahn Academy class.
You have a different and better brain
and it will matter to you.
It will count on the positive
side for the point of view
of your neurological
capacities, of course.
You have this resource.
Every one of us has this resource.
How effectively are you using it?
And I wish every young person,
I wish every adult could understand
that they're probably under
utilizing this resource, right?
And undervaluing it.
Best way to throw away this asset
is just to accept the fact
that you have some dark fate,
that means you have no real potential
because that's who you are.
What a silly and scientifically
incorrect attitude that is.